so there's always levels to training so
maybe at first you kind of just learned
the hand pass
and the tsukiyashi
okay
and you have to get that stuff but
if you stay there
then
that's not good
okay you only have one level that means
no levels okay
so
um
what i'm trying to do for those that
have done this for a while
is
right right from the start
you have that center connection uh so
you can see
you're already in the center okay
but i i'm yielding
as i'm doing it so at
any point you still have
that center connection okay i'm not
going like this
so i don't come back this way and lose
that center connection and i'm just
doing the arm pass okay
so you're you're in that body
up to this point and then guess what
this arm is in that body too
okay
not here here
and you're just moving to the side of
that
okay
so of course when you first start yes
just learn the arm pass and then just
learn to speak up that's gonna be fine
okay
but advanced whole you want to feel his
body feeling his body
so you could always project
the body oh and same thing same thing
here if you see the same projection
point
and same thing going all the way around
you still have that same projection
ability
okay
so
feel his mass
and move his mass in a way that it all
moves okay the whole thing is moving
oh
it is not my ukia running around me
okay
so i always like to demonstrate this
you're going to do a pulling he's
pulling you see
okay so
[Music]
you're still moving that mass
he's doing a push
it has the same thing i'm still in his
body still in his body moving his whole
body as one unit
okay
try to get this
so i i have his center in this
arm and what i'm doing is passing it
to two arms simultaneously right here
both arms are in his center not
one this is just touching
both arms are both arms in his body both
arms are in his body
both arms are in his body and then
you're going to pass all control over to
one hand do you see that one hand is in
his body
and now guess what you're going to do
it's going to go back to two hands
oftentimes you just pay attention to
this and this hand is just laying there
not doing anything
one hand in his body hold one hand in
his body two hands in his body
one hand in his body
two hands in his body
[Music]
oh
this is different
okay two hands keep
the connection
okay let's
i'm not trying to do a technique right
now i'm using kimono to learn a skill
okay
i'm not interested in leaving it i don't
think it even knows yet okay
so
boom
do you feel that okay so right away
center connection
oh
this is going off didn't it
okay so watch the difference
[Music]
leave it on leave it on both hands are
on right
okay oh
[Music]
okay
and all i'm doing is using her whole
body
[Music]
it goes into one hand and then it comes
back into that
it's kind of like a crushing feeling
right that's what i'm trying to do
[Music]
as soon as you grab
and there we are you feel that okay so
again you're just
a little bit
into projection okay
so what we don't want to see how it goes
off
do you feel that yeah because you change
your face
okay so it's on
even though i'm moving
you this way it's staying on and the
point i'm trying to make is if it's on
that you can see that it can go back
into the center okay it's not it's not
this
you see that difference that that can
never go back into your ascension
it's not going to go bad okay
so i have your connection and i'm going
to move you and you i'm moving your
whole body okay now it went off in it
so it's gonna stay on
and the two hands are gonna go together
two hands together and now it went off
didn't you feel that
okay so it doesn't go off
oh
okay you see that
and this hand is part of the arm so i
feel this difference
there
one the two hands are on okay on what
the hell does that mean okay it means
that
i can move your center
means i am moving your center okay i am
moving her center
if you want to
pull backwards it doesn't matter i'm
moving her body
very much
like i'm grabbing here and i pull this
thing okay
what i'm not doing is grabbing here
and trying to move her shoulders do you
understand
so
in moving her center and when i touch
this hand both together touches your
center
that's what's making her come around but
somebody you're doing is kind of on off
you feel that difference off over here
and then you're
like trying to do something like that
in in
okay
can you feel that yeah it feels totally
different okay try it please